welcome
to this tutorial on pseudo-boolean
solving and optimization which is part
of the boot camp
for the satisfiability theory practice
and beyond program at the simons
institute for the theory of computing
so we have reached part three of this
pre-recorded tutorial
in part one we learned what
pseudo-boolean constraints and
pseudo-boolean formulas are
pseudo-boolean formulas are collections
of zero-one integer linear inequalities
in pseudo-boolean solving you want to
determine whether cytok
such a collection of inequalities
is satisfiable is feasible or not we saw
that we could use the ideas
of conflict-driven search in cdcl
solvers
to solve this problem either by taking
the pseudo-boolean formulas and
rewriting them to conjunctive normal
form so that we can feed them to cdcl
solver directly
or in the other direction we can take
the conflict-driven paradigm and try to
lift it
from cdcl to uh
native pseudo-boolean reasoning
where we do propagation and conflict
analysis not on disjunctive clauses
but on general zero one integer linear
inequalities
and if you survived till the end of part
two which was a fairly
long video chunk then
you saw that there are different ways of
doing this there are lots of degrees of
freedom
lots of questions that have not been
fully
explored compared to cdcl
um and so i'd say there are
lots of good open research problems
there and this is even more so
when now here in part three we consider
the setting where
in addition to the pseudo boolean
formula you also have a linear objective
function
that you want to minimize so this is
what we want to talk about now
and this topic
is connected to max sat solving and many
of the ideas for pseudo-boolean
optimization come from max ad solving
and have been most fully developed there
so we'll talk about max ad solving and
then we'll talk about the ideas
for for how to solve max ad problems and
in general suitable in optimization
problems using linear search
or core guided search or implicit
hitting set approaches or combinations
of them so as already said
pseudo boolean optimization and max sat
solving
are closely related in order to make
this precise let us
first define what maxsat is
let's define the fully general weighted
partial max that problem
so this is where we have a cnf formula
as input
but the clauses come in two
types we have soft clauses c1 up to cm
each clause equipped with a weight w i
which is some positive real numbers i
think for today it's it's better to
think of them as positive integer
numbers and then we have a
bunch of hard crosses c m plus one up to
c capital m
and our goal is to find an assignment
row
that has to satisfy all the hard clauses
and then we want to maximize
the amount of soft clauses that we
satisfy so we
sum up the weights of all the satisfied
soft clauses and this is our
objective except that from now on
and for the rest of this talk we'll
think about this as a minimization
problem instead remember that
we want to think of our pseudo boolean
optimization problems as minimization
problems
but here it's fairly natural we can
minimize the penalty
of the soft clauses that we fail to
satisfy that we falsify
and we can write a c a sub w
for a soft clause c with weight w and we
can write a hard clause just a c
sub infinity and it's natural to think
of a hard clause as a clause
with infinite weight because then
obviously if we want to minimize the
penalty then we cannot afford
to falsify a single such clause because
then our objective value is infinity
so here is an example max at instance we
have a unit clause not x with weight 5
a clause y or not said with weight four
a clause not y or z with weight three
and then two hard clauses
x or y or z x or not y or not said
and it is easy and natural to translate
this to a pseudo boolean optimization
problem
in the following way so we just take
these all of these clauses and we can
write them
as in in the pseudo for boolean form
by just summing up the literals and
saying that there should be greater
equal zero
but for the soft clauses for every soft
clause we
add an individual new variable
so b1 for clause 1 b2 for clause 2 and
b3 for clause 3 and we add it to the
clause
and now um it is a
common assumption in mac set solving
that the hard
part of the formula consisting of the
hard clauses is satisfiable because
otherwise we have an onset instance and
there's nothing to optimize
so given that the hard clauses are
satisfiable once i've added these new
variables b clearly this is a
satisfiable instance because
all of these soft clauses i can just set
the b variables to true and then they're
satisfied
but now what i want to minimize is the
number of such
b variables that i actually use so it's
not hard to see so i have
and and i minimize by multiplying
each variable bi by the weight of clause
ci
and it's not hard to see that this is
essentially now the same problem
so this is the so-called blocking
variable transformation where the bis
are the blocking variables and we can
see here that
an optimal solution sets x to zero and z
to zero
y to one that violates only the cheapest
soft clause
uh so it incurs a penalty of three
in the other direction we can also take
a
general pseudo boolean optimization
problem and translate it into a max at
the instance except that it might
contain
pseudo-boolean constraints instead of
disjunctive clauses
so in the literature such max sat
instances in quotes are known as
weighted boolean optimization problems
so here is a pseudo boolean optimization
instance
we want to minimize some wi
li where the
li or literals subject to constraint c1
up to cm
to translate this into maxsat we
just take all the literals
in the objective function we negate them
and we make them into soft unit clauses
with weight equal to the coefficient
and then all the hard all the all the
original constraints in the
pseudo-boolean instance they turn into
hard constraints with uh infinite weight
so it's clear that a
pseudo boolean instance in such way is
just a max set instance or
or more generally a weighted boolean
optimization instance
and so you could in principle take a
suitable
optimization instance translate it in
this way
if these are general pseudo-boolean
constraints you could
translate these pseudo-boolean
constraints into cnf
as we discussed in part two and then you
could run your favorite maxsat solver
and then it would work as a general
pseudo-boolean
optimization solver
so the maxsat problem comes in in four
flavors
if we have only soft clauses then it's
the
original traditional maxsat problem if
we have both hard and soft clauses then
it's known as
partial maxsat and then you can have
weighted or unweighted versions of these
problems
where in the unweighted version all the
soft clauses have the same weight
which then without loss of generality we
consider can consider to be one
so this gives us four different flavors
of max sat
but the distinction is not so important
these days apparently because
most of the best solvers they uh
deal with our loss of generality with
with the most general problem so we
in what follows we'll just talk about
weighted partial max set
and the main approach is
for solving weighted partial max sat and
sudo boolean optimization
that are used in current
state-of-the-art solvers
are linear search known as a linear
search sat
onsat or model improving search we'll
start
talking about this and then we will
talk about another approach that is
called core guided search
and then finally i'll mention something
briefly about implicit hitting set
approaches for solving macset
and pseudo-boolean optimization
and throughout our perspective will be
we'll think about the problem of
minimizing
an objective function summing over i
w i l i subject to a collection of
pseudo boolean constraints c1 up to cm
which could be disjunctive clauses or
maybe a general sudo boolean constraints
so what this means is in some sense we
if it's a max sat problem then we've
already done this
blocking variable transformation
good so what is linear search well it's
the
perhaps the the most natural
approach you could think of we uh
just run the server so we start
out by saying that we don't have a
solution so the best solution is
nothingness and then we're on our solver
in macset it's a set solver
if it's a pseudo boolean optimization
problem and maybe it's a pseudo boolean
solver
if the solver returns unsatisfiable then
we output whatever we have as the best
solution and terminate
otherwise we found a solution row an
assignment to the variables
let's update row best to be this
solution
and then we can evaluate the objective
function
and under row this gives value wi
times rho i summing over i from 1 to n
and now we add a constraint asking for
an objective function value that is one
smaller than this
so we add this constraint and then we
run the solver again
so now next time either it will have to
return a better solution
in which case we update or if it turns
out that we already found the best
solution
then the solver will return
unsatisfiable and then we return the
best solution
here is a small toy example suppose we
have a pseudo boolean formula f
which we'll just consider to be a black
box we don't know what it is
but the objective function is minimizing
say
x1 plus 2x2 plus 3x3 plus 4x4
plus 5x5 plus 6x6 okay
good we run the solver and it returns
the assignment that x1 up to x3 and x6
are zero but x4 and x5 are
one so now we evaluate the objective
so we get a contribution only from x4
and x5
and the others contribute zero so the
objective
function value here is nine now we want
a better solution than this so we add
the constraint that the objective
function should be less than
equal eight note that this is not a
normalized
constraint because it is not a greater
than or equal constraint
but we agreed already in part one of
this tutorial that we know how to
convert this into normalized form and
here it is convenient
to use this syntactic sugar to think of
this as a less than or equal constraint
good we run the solver again on the
original formula f
plus this new constraint in red and now
suppose it sets
x1 x3 x5 and x6 to 0
but x2 and x4 to 1.
then the objective value is six
so we add a constraint saying that we
want the objective
uh function to be less equal five
and we run this over again and now
suppose the solver returns unsatisfiable
so this means that there it wasn't
possible to
find a solution to the pseudo boolean
formula f
that yielded objective function value 5
or smaller
but we do have a solution with value six
that has to be the optimal solution so
we can return six
as the optimal that's
linear search and now
especially if you're uh know your your
algorithms you're a theoretician you ask
well
well why are we doing linear search why
are we not doing
binary search here and
the answer is that apparently
linear search is better
so there are at least two possible
explanations
for this one is that well in theory why
is linear search bad linear search is
bad
because it could be that you just
improve the objective value
by an additive one so you have to rerun
it and rerun it over and over again and
you get
only very small gains in objective
function value
in practice apparently this does not
happen so much
even when you do linear search the
objective function value tends to jump
quite a bit another
perhaps more important reason is that
when you're doing binary search and
you're using
a sat or pseudo boolean solver as an
oracle
and not all calls to this oracle have
equal cost because some of the calls
will be for satisfiable instances where
you just want to find a solution that is
better than the solution you already
have but there is such a solution
and then some calls will be onset calls
which is where the solver determines
that you're asking for
an objective function value that is too
good to be true
and it tends to be the case that these
unset calls are more expensive
than the sap calls so if you do a binary
search then it might be that every
you know a lot of a lot of your calls
might be unset calls and so they might
be quite expensive
compared to going
with linear search and getting all calls
sat calls
until only a final expensive onset call
another nice property of linear search
is that you get a solution fairly
quickly
even if it's not the optimal solution
even after the first
time your solver returns you have some
solution
and then you work on improve it but you
have something and this is important for
what is sometimes referred to as any
time solving which is a setup where
you don't only solve for optimality
but time is also limited so you're
interested at every point in time to
have the best
possible solution available with that
limited
amount of computation and it can be
argued that in applied settings this is
a very important setting quite often you
might not
have patience to wait for hours and
hours to squeeze the final
bit of optimality out to your solution
if you can get an almost optimal
solution quickly
then you're very happy with that but the
problem of course with with linear
search is you don't know how good your
solution is
because you have no handle on
what the lower bound might be
so that's what i wanted to say about uh
linear search sat
on sat or the lsu algorithm now
uh we switch gears and talk about
so-called
core guided search we still want to
minimize
the sum uh w-i-l-i summing from
for i goes from one to n subject to some
collection of pseudo-boolean constraints
and when i want to describe core guided
search
um it's convenient to first uh
think of this as a mac sat instance
where li
are these blocking variables that we
have introduced so every
the meaning now of a literal li is that
it represents a soft clause
and and this is the reason why this is
important is that this
explains some of the the terminology
that is used although we will generalize
it shortly
so now the idea is the following we want
to be optimistic
so we say that in fact the best possible
value
is zero we can minimize everything we
can set all the literals to zero
and we run the set solver
since we're doing max at we run the sat
solver with these assumptions
assuming li to zero for all literals in
the objective function
and usually sat solvers have a special
api
where you can tell it to in addition to
the decisions that it's going to make on
its own
you give it a list of pre-made decisions
to be applied at the beginning
and then what the sat solver will do it
will apply all these decisions
and then it will either find a solution
that is consistent with these pre-made
decisions these assumptions
or it will return an explanation
a clause showing why
these assumptions are not consistent
okay why you can't make all of these
assumptions so we run the solver
and now it should be clear that if it
returns satisfiable
then we have indeed found the optimal
solution because we were wildly
optimistic but this bet
paid off we found a fantastic solution
so we're happy
clearly zero is the best we could hope
for
since all the weights wi are are
non-negative otherwise
what the solver does it's returning some
clause that explains why the assumptions
are inconsistent so say the
learned clause is li or
l1 or l2 up to lk which says that no no
you cannot assume l1 l2 up to lk
all false at least one of these
literals has to be true
and what this means in a max set setting
is no
you have to violate at least one of
these soft clauses
you cannot find a satisfying assignment
that satisfies all the hard constraints
plus all of these soft clauses this is
not possible
and in max set terminology that means
that these soft clauses
c1 up to ck form a core
okay this is what is known as a core and
this is why it's called core guided
search
so now we know that in this core at
least
one clause has to be false
at least one blocking variable
li has to be used
but possibly more we don't know maybe
all of them so
we have to violate at least one of these
clauses maybe all k of them
we don't know how many so conceptually
we now introduce
new variables zj
where we think of zj as meaning
that j out of these literals l1
up to lk um are true
that j of the soft clauses have to be
falsified and then
we can update our objective function
by using the equality
that we know that well the sum of the l
i
is at least 1 plus
summing for j goes from 2 to k zj for
these new variables j
and now we can use this equality we can
plug it into the objective function
and we will multiply it
by the smallest coefficient
of any li and then we'll get a
cancellation
we'll cancel that li and we'll
substitute the zjs instead and we'll get
out the constant term here
that will give us an update that says
that well this is a lower bound
on what you could hope to achieve you
can't get all the way down to zero
you have to have an additive term at
least such and such and this allows us
to update the best value
so this is going very fast and i'm not
explaining it very well
um but we'll do an example uh shortly a
more general
uh pseudo boolean optimization example
so bear with me for a minute
the important thing is that in some way
we can
introduce these new variables which have
the intended meaning
that some of l1 up to lk
is equal to 1 plus sum of z2
up to zk and then we can use this
equality to rewrite the objective
get an updated lower bound estimate
and then we just keep this
we store this additive lower bound
somewhere
and then we assume that
the rest of the objective function can
again be zero and then we repeat from
the start and we just
run this over and over again deriving
new course
okay until we get the answer satisfiable
back
and when that happens the current
estimate best
value is indeed an optimal solution
okay and this uh original uh
id in maxsat comes from a paper by by
phu and malik and has been
developed in a number of different
directions
so see this survey in the references
again the references
will are at the end of the slides and
you find the pdf with the slides
on the simons institute webpage i will
also
show uh the slides in the fourth
and final video in this pre-recorded
tutorial
they are at the end of of of
the pdf file with my slides
and you can view core guided search it's
again a linear search but it's not sat
on sat it's coming
from the onset side and moving towards
the sat side
and this idea of of introducing these
new variables to keep track of
how much of the core is violated
has been used in in answer set
programming in in max sat solving
so now we want to translate all of this
to a general
pseudo-boolean setting and now the nice
thing here first is that we don't need
to think of the
allies as blocking variables or markers
for soft clauses or something we just
have
a general pseudo-boolean problem this is
an objective function
whatever the allies are just literals
there are no soft clauses
no nothing around we'll still talk about
cores but there are no like there will
be no
soft clauses or anything okay
um another thing is that this rewriting
that we did
i'm going back again will actually be
very convenient here
because in a max set setting if you want
to actually encode this
you'd have to rewrite to cnf's in some
way
but in a pseudo boolean setting this
will just be an equality is just two
pseudo boolean constraints
that you can just write down and then
you're done i'm sweeping a little bit of
details under the rug
but essentially this is very cheap in a
pseudo boolean setting
because the constraints that you need
are already available as native
constraints
for the solver so
you can do core guided pseudo boolean
search which just assumes that the
objective function you have
can reach its best imaginable value and
then you derive a contradiction if this
is not possible
and essentially run the algorithm we
have on the
previous uh slide so let me rather than
giving you pseudo code because it gets a
bit
messy let me just try to explain the
idea by a
concrete toy example in fact the same
example as before
we have this pseudo boolean formula f
i'm not telling you what it is
but we have the objective x1
plus 2x2 plus all the way up to 5x5
plus 6x6 and now we're going to solve
this
pseudo boolean optimization problem with
corrugated search
so the first assumption is that well
the best possible value is 0 right so we
set all
the variables x i to zero and run the
solver
and now also a pseudo boolean solver can
be
developed to have this assumption mode
where it will do one of two things
it will apply all the assumptions then
it will solve
the residual pseudo boolean formula
under these assumptions
and it will either return a solution in
which case we're happy
or it will return
a pseudo-boolean constraint that
explains
why these assumptions are inconsistent
how do you do this well in technical
terms it's not so hard you just
run your solver on with with the
standard conflict analysis and then once
you know you can extract the core when
you get a conflict already at the level
that is at the decision level of the
last assumption or earlier because if
you get a
conflict in the solver only after
applying assumptions
then you know that the conflict is
explained
only by your assumptions now if you run
your standard
learning algorithm you might pick up
other literals also
but you can switch to the so-called
decision learning scheme which
resolves the way all reasons all the way
up to the
the beginning of the trail and then you
will get
a constraint that only involves
the assumption variables so suppose that
we get such a constraint back and and it
turns out that the constraint is 3x2
plus 2x3 plus x4 plus x5 greater or
equal four
say okay
um so it turns out that
this constraint if i want to do pattern
matching on the on the
max sat core guided algorithm we had
before
it's not so easy to deal with this
general pseudo boolean constraint so
as we discussed in part two of the
tutorial you can take any pseudo boolean
constraint and you can round it
to a cardinality constraint so i can
look at this constraint and i can say
what's the best cardinality constraint i
can
get from it well if the only way that
this constraint is true
is that at least two of these variables
have to be true
so i'll round this constraint to a
constraint
saying x2 plus x3 plus x4 plus x5
greater or equal to this is certainly
implied by the pseudo-boolean
core constraint and i'll call this
cardinality constraint the cardinality
core constraint
so now we want to do now we know that
the sum of these variables is at least
two the pseudo boolean solver told us
this
and the sum can be at most four
clearly but we don't know where it is
between
two and four and we want to store this
information
and the way we're going to do this we're
going to introduce
two new fresh variables y3 and y4
and write down pseudo boolean
constraints again i'm using syntactic
sugar here but it should not be hard to
see that
these are actually pseudobullet
constraints first i'll write down
constraints enforcing
that x1 x2 plus x3 plus x4 plus 65
is equal to 2 plus
y3 plus y4 and the reason why this is
sound
i mean this would not be a sound
constraint in general but we know
that the sum of these variables is at
least two the solver told us this
so that's why we can write down this
constraint and then i'll also enforce
that y3 is greater or equal by 4 and now
if you
think about it for a second you realize
that this
these constraints 4a and 4b actually
enforce
what i wanted it to enforce namely that
yj is true precisely
if sum of x2 up to x5 is greater equal j
so now what i want to do next is
i want to update the objective function
using this so let's go back to the
previous slide
and here is the objective function
in one and in 4a i have an equality
so i can multiply this equality by
2 and then i can substitute
y2 well because i look at what the
coefficients of x2 x3 x4 and x5
are and the smallest coefficient is 2.
okay
so i multiply the equality 4a by
2 and then i can substitute
2x2 plus 2x3 plus 2x4
plus 2x5 i can substitute that
by 2 times 2 that's 4
plus 2 y 3 plus 2 y
4 because this is an equality
let's do that so here is the new
objective function which is equivalent
to the old objective function because
because of these constraints
4 a and 4b that i've introduced
the original objective function 1 is
equivalent to this modified objective
function
5. and note that in this new objective
function 5
i have picked up a constant term 4
which indeed tells me what i learned
from this cardinality core
namely that
[Music]
it is not possible to achieve zero
for this objective function so far i
know that the best possible value
is four maybe four isn't achievable
either
but you can't do better than four
good so now i run the solver again
assuming all literals to being 0 in the
updated objective function so i assume
x1 x3
x4 x5 and x6 to 0 note that x2 cancel
then is no longer around
in addition i assume y 3 and y 4 to 0.
let's run the solver again and see what
happens so it turns out that the solar
now returns not a general pseudo boolean
constraint it just
returns a a clause
that will happen a fair amount of the
time you'll just get a clause back in
here
suppose we get the clause x4 plus x5
plus
x6 plus y3 at least one of these
literals is true
and what do we now again we want to we
know that at least one of these literal
is
true we know that four of them could be
true we don't know
whether you know one or two or three or
four of them will be true we want to
store this information so we'll
introduce new variables again
and so since we already have a clause
there's no need to rewrite
a general pseudo boolean constraint to a
cardinality constraint because this is
already a cardinality constraint
so we introduce new variables that two
said 3 and set 4
and we can write down this equality then
that x
4 plus x 5 plus x 6 plus y 3
is equal to 1 plus z 2 plus
z 3 plus z 4. and this is sound because
we have this lower bound in 6. so that's
why we can plug in this one
and then we add in addition constraints
that z2
is greater equal z3 that is greater
equals z4
and these constraints 7a to 7c will
enforce
the meaning of zj as
the sum of x4 x5 x6 and y3 is greater
equal j
and now what we're going to do again
is we're going to look at the
coefficients
we want to use this equality 7a and
update
the objective function and now x4
x 6 x 4 appears with coefficient 2
x 5 with coefficient 3 x
6 with coefficient 6 y 3 with
coefficient
2 that means that we can multiply this
whole equality
with a 2 and then substitute
2 times the left hand side
here we can replace that by 2 times the
right hand side
so 2 z2 plus 2z3
plus 2z4 plus a constant term 2
that will provide a further update of
the lower bound estimate
in our objective function so let's see
what we get we get this
so now we have an equivalent
objective function again x1 plus x3 plus
x5
plus 4x6 plus 2y4
note that y3 canceled here and also
uh x4 cancelled and instead we have
two z2 plus two set three
plus two z4 plus the four we had before
is now updated to six
so now we see that we don't know what
the
optimal value is but it's at least six
so the best value estimate we update it
to six
and now for the third time we run the
solver again and we
assume all of these literals in the
objective
function to false
okay and now you remember in our linear
search toy example there was in fact a
solution with value six
so that should be the case here as well
and indeed
our sudo boolean solver finds it it
reports that
x1 equals x3 equals 65 equals 66
equals y4 z2 z3 z4 all of them
can be assumed to false and there is
such a solution
fantastic so
then we know from this
that we can read off the the original
solution we can go back for instance so
if the solver
doesn't already tell us then we can
figure out ourselves from 4a
which was this constraint where we
introduced y3 and y4
so when we apply this
partial assignment
4a simplifies to x2 plus x4
is equal to 2 plus y3 and the only way
this holds can hold is that y 3 is
0 and x 2 and x 4 are 1 so that means
that we can read off the original
solution
in the x variables and indeed
we get so x2
and x4 are one and all the others are
zero
and looking at the original objective
function
we had x2 and x4 1 and all the other
zero so indeed
we do get objective value six but this
we already knew
because uh note that due to our
rewriting
this objective function in eight is
equivalent to the original one because
we only transformed it
using equalities
okay so this is an explanation by
example of how how core guided search
works and what are some
interested properties of this algorithm
if we run this pure
corrugated search that i discussed here
well
it turns out that we can if we're lucky
we can quickly get a
lower bound on the solution and this is
nice because
this helps us if we have a good lower
bound that this
already allows us to ignore large parts
of the search space
where the objective function value would
just be too good to be true
however the way the algorithm
works here we have we know nothing about
the solution until we
finally hit on the optimal solution so
we know nothing until we have the
optimal one
and depending on what you want you know
this
might not be what you're after
also uh although we do have a lower
bound we have no idea how
far away this lower bound or from a
feasib
is from a feasible solution because
we're only increasing the lower bound
so this is complementary to linear
search which was good at finding an
a solution an upper bound but there we
had no clue about the lower bound so
it's a very natural question to ask
well maybe can we somehow combine core
guided search and linear search to to
to get matching upper and lower bounds
here are some ideas that have been
explored for how to do this
the first one is stratification or
weight stratification you look at the
objective function
and maybe some literals have very heavy
coefficients and other ones have
have not so heavy coefficients so some
coefficients are large
others are small and if there's a
large difference in coefficient weights
then
do the assumption only assuming
literals with large weight coefficients
to false
but don't assume anything about the
others
so this can lead to one of two things
so if it turns out that already this
very limited assumption
on these large weight literals
if already that is inconsistent then
since you made small
fewer assumptions you get a smaller more
compact core a stronger core
okay another thing that can happen is of
course that well
in fact assuming these high weight
literals
to false was consistent so you find you
sort of accidentally find the solution
but that's great because then we have
now we actually have a decent solution
and we can can continue our core guided
search but we have at least some kind of
solution and
note that this was what the linear
search gave us before but that
we were missing in the pure core guided
search approach
another idea to amortize the work
done as it were during during the the
core guided search is if we
assume all the allies from say one to n
to false and then we learn a core
constraint that only involves l1 up to
lk
then we can say okay now we know that at
least one of these literals
has to be true what about the other ones
maybe there are
other connections in between the other
literals that we have not explored so
let's just remove
l1 up to lk
from the list of assumptions let's
assume the other literals
to false and run the solver again with
these remaining assumptions
and if we now get a new core then
obviously this core will be
disjoint from the core we previously had
over
l1 up to lk so in this way we can
collect
a number of disjoint cores and then we
can
update uh the
objective function and get a lower bound
update
independently with with all of these
independent cores
disjoint course individually
contributing
to the update of the objective
function lower bound
another idea is called core boosting so
here what we do is
is remember that i said that the nice
thing with
core guided search is that it can
quickly give us
a fairly decent uh lower bound on the
objective function that
that cuts off large part of the search
space so with core boosting you just do
that you run courier search for a while
to hopefully get this good lower bound
estimate
and then you switch to linear search and
stay with linear search
and try to find an optimal solution
hoping that the lower bound during the
core
boosted you the lower bound that you
found from core
boosting during the core guided search
helps you to do this
a more refined idea is to
interleave core guided and unlinear
search
so that you would start doing maybe core
guided then switch to linear search for
a while
then switch back to query added search
and again do linear search
now this apparently is not done much
in max sat solvers and my understanding
is that the reason for this
is in fact that all of these steps that
i described
with updates of the objective function
and rewriting note that we were
operating with
pseudo-boolean constraints
and this doesn't come for free because
in a cnf setting there's a lot of
re-encoding involved
and this is fairly expensive and takes
time so
so doing this switching back and forth
between core guide and linear search is
fairly costly
if you're operating on cnfs but if
you're operating
natively on pseudo boolean constraints
then in fact this is not expensive
at all then you can do full interleaving
search fairly cheaply
so this is another advantage of a native
pseudo boolean solver
one thing that we cannot do in a
pseudo-boolean solver
at least not yet but you can do in a
cdcl solver just as in cdcl conflict
analysis you
you do clause minimization during
learning
here you can also do core minimization
because the core that you learned is
just a learned clause as any other
clause so you can try to minimize
the core in different ways
for a pseudo-boolean solver it's not so
clear how to do this but
maybe something can be done although to
the best of my knowledge
i don't know of anything that
has been implemented in this regard and
i i should note that this
in general this idea of minimizing the
constraints that you learned during
conflict analysis
is is an interesting problem for
pseudo-boolean conflict analysis in
general
one implementation detail that
turns out to be important um
is that when we did this rewriting let's
go back and see
uh time and again we
had these equalities where we introduced
here for instance we introduced
new variables z2 said three you said
four and
and did this uh rewriting
now in a real world instance you'll find
many many cores and if these cores are
large
and are clausal then you'll get tons of
new variables
and in fact performance will take a hit
after a while
and then it turns out that you could
sort of be
lazy here and
not introduce
z3 and said four you could just
introduce z2
you'll have to use a different encoding
but you could just introduce z2
to mean as an indicator that
in fact more than one of these literals
are true
and then introduce z3 and z4 later only
when needed
so this is something that is called
lazy
variables lazy introduction of variables
here we are
and um this can be pretty important
um but i didn't describe it here because
conceptually it's not really a
difference it's more of an
implementation detail
so why is core guided search good i
don't
know but from a from a theoretical point
of view one
very interesting observation is that
these new variables that we're
introducing they are extension variables
and we know uh from proof complexity
that even just the resolution proof
system
if you add extension variables then it
becomes extremely powerful it becomes as
powerful as extended frega which is
one of the strongest proof systems that
we know and also if we take a
pseudo-boolean solver and add extension
variables
to it then it becomes some version of
cutting planes with extension variables
which is also equally strong
it takes us all the way to to extended
fragrance
now the problem with why these
proof systems with extension variables
are not used
is that although they're strong in
theory it's very hard to see
in practice what would be good
heuristics
to introduce extension variables and
make use of them
but what is interesting here is that
core guided search provides
such heuristic for which extension
variables you should introduce
and why so one
interesting question from a theoretical
point of view would be to
formalize what core guided search can do
and given that extension variables are
introduced in this way
it would also be interesting to to
characterize
limits of the powers of this method to
see if we can pin down
maybe there are some things that it
cannot do to a better theoretical
understanding here
would be quite interesting
um this i just want to report
uh briefly this is actually something
that we uh
try to do if we try to evaluate
we implemented core guided search in a
pseudo boolean solver in the solver
rounding set that was mentioned in part
two of this tutorial
and we have explored different flavors
of this
combining core guided search and linear
search
and let me present on a bunch of
different
benchmark families a number of instances
that are sold to optimality
with different approaches the best solar
configuration in red then blue then
green
and don't look at the last line of this
table for now
try to just don't look at it we'll
discuss the other lines first
[Music]
so our favorite setting
was the software that dynamically
interleaves
core guided search and linear search and
switches back and forth
this was a competitive approach in
general
so we run it on the sued latest pseudo
boolean competition from 2016
the 16 000 um competition benchmarks
there's also a map lib that is used for
evaluations in the in the mixed integer
linear programming
community we took some zero one
integer linear programs from there
optimization problems
run on those there's a collection
of knapsack challenging knapsack
instances by pissinger
[Music]
and then for other
reasons somewhat somewhat independently
somewhat depending on this
we have a collection of tricky uh
benchmarks originating in proof
complexity so these
these are combinatorial formulas which
are sometimes referred to
over on the applied side as crafted
formulas so we have a particularly
tricky set of crafted formulas that
challenge the solvers in different kinds
of theoretical ways
measuring their strength of inference
and we can see that the hybrid solver
overall performed very well
on these benchmarks
compared to the rounding set version
that we had before
that only does linear search
you see that it's a fairly significant
jump in performance on the pseudo
boolean competition benchmarks
uh and even more so on the crafted
benchmarks
interestingly for knapsack
linear search is still better
and for the mid instances are in general
just
hard for pseudo-boolean solvers but at
least it seems that
hybrid helps helps a bit another very
competitive approach as we can see is
the core guided approach where you don't
interleave but
10 of the time we run query added search
and then we switch
and until the timeout we just run linear
search that's also very good
we try to investigate
how much the different aspects of the
implementation contribute
so one interesting thing with
pseudo-boolean solvers is that the
clause
the cores are not necessarily clausal
they can be general cardinality
constraints
so we try to switch this on and off
and we can see that the fact that you
can get non-closal cores
actually seems to contribute fairly
significantly
not always but usually there's a
boost in performance when you can have
also known clausal course
lazy variables are very important if you
want to solve knapsack and this is
because
for the knapsack constraints you have
lots of different weights
and it turns out that you can get very
many
new variables if you're not lazy so
that's why you have this huge jump here
and then we tried uh this interleaving
solver
with uh both uh
lazy variables switched off and the
non-causal core switched off
and as expected it's mostly
worst not always but for most of the
instances
um
so here we can see we're evaluating
against two other pseudo boolean solvers
such for j that i've been mentioning
before and nabs which is a cdcl based
solver
they are very competitive or even better
than this linear search rounding set on
the sudo boolean competition
benchmarks but we see that once we throw
in this core guided
component running set gets much much
better
except for knapsack
where it seems that the the tricky part
is to find good solutions and here
somehow
running sat is not doing well now
finally the sad part
is that skip is an is a
an academic mip solver it's not the best
map solver but it's the best
non-closed source solver and
unfortunately it beats the crap out of
all
uh pseudo-boolean solvers so there's
room for improvement here and this is
why you should also stick around for
part four of this tutorial where we'll
talk a little bit about what solvers
like skip do
but i should say that there are
[Music]
skip and the hybrid rounding stat solver
have somewhat complementary
uh strengths also it should be noted
that skip
uses pre-processing and and none of this
pseudo boolean solvers do that so maybe
we should do that
i think there's room for for improvement
here by taking the best techniques from
skip and the best techniques from
from uh pseudo boolean solvers and try
to combine them
and maybe also uh use other
techniques like the implicit hitting set
approach that we'll discuss
shortly
oh yeah here are also a plot
from a cumulative plot
for the pseudo boolean competition 2016
benchmarks
so here we're plotting number of sold
instances
as a function of time with a logarithmic
scale
and here we also tried to
introduce these ideas with weight
stratification and trying to find
independent course
interestingly for the instances in the
pseudo boolean competition benchmark set
it it
turns out that this doesn't pay off so
so
weight stratification is not such a big
difference
sometimes it pays off sometimes it
doesn't it's actually hit or miss
whether you want to use stratification
or not but independent course
doesn't seem to be good so
one possible explanation for this could
be maybe selection bias
that because there is a selection bias
in this
these competition competition benchmark
sets
or maybe we uh somehow didn't uh
implement the independent course as it's
done
in the best state-of-the-art max ad
solvers or maybe it's something else
entirely we don't know
that's what i wanted to say about
core guided suru boolean optimizers now
the
final third and final approach i want to
talk about
i'll do it more briefly is the so-called
implicit hitting set algorithm
again recall that we have this generic
setting
we want to minimize sum from for i goes
from 1 to n w i
li for literals li subject to some
collection
of pseudo-boolean constraints and since
we're coming from maxsat again let's
think of these as clausal constraints
let's think of these lie as blocking
literals so they're they're names
of um
of of clauses as it were
so as in core guided search we'll solve
with assumptions
and we'll collect cores but we collect
a whole set of them and keep this set
so cores will be clauses and the meaning
of this clause
so the again the these literals l are
like names of literals and the first
course says that well you have to
falsify at least one of these clauses
and then the second core says you have
to falsify this is one of these clauses
and the core number s
says that you have to falsify at least
one of
one of the clauses tagged by these
literals
okay so in all of these sets you have to
falsify at least
one clause now one way of
of trying to do this as economically as
possible
is well pick as few literals as possible
so that you hit all of these clauses
so pick a hitting set so this is what
we're going to do
so the way the implicit testing set
approach is
we start with a set of course that is
empty at the outset
and will grow with the course that we
collect and in every
iteration we compute a minimum hitting
set for k
that is a set of literals
such that every clause
in the core set has some literal in h
so in terms of sets h is a hitting set
what this means for truth value
assignments is that if we set all the
literals
in age to true then we're satisfying all
of these clauses
and we know that we have to so
satisfying all of these clauses means
that we're
violating some
original clause in these cores
and this we know we have to do and we're
trying to do it the fact that we're
using a minimum
minimum weight hitting set means that
we're trying to
falsify soft clauses in the cheapest way
possible
and once we've figured out this minimum
hitting set h
we run the solver with the this
assumption
so the literals in the hitting set we'll
assume them to true
we take the penalty everything else we
try to assume to false
now if the solver run with this
assumption
finds a solution it must be an optimal
solution
because we know that
we know that we have to we have to pick
one literal from
all of these clauses and the minimum
hitting set is doing this in the most
economical way possible
so therefore if the solar finds the
solution with the minimum weight hitting
set
then this solution is optimal and we can
return this value
otherwise if the solver does not find a
solution it returns a new core
which we add to k and then we start over
again compute the new hitting set
and do another round of this iteration
and one observation is that we
when are we using minimality we're only
using minimality here
but when the solar finds the solution
it's optimal since the hitting set is
optimal so this means that in
early iterations we can just compute
decent hitting sets not necessarily
optimal ones we only need to check
optimality at the very end
so a natural question is yeah but where
do we find the hitting sets
so but it's not so hard to see that this
minimum weight heating set is in fact
another pseudo boolean optimization
problem
we even discussed this in the
preliminaries part of the tutorial
so you could actually imagine
running your solver on this sub problem
and taking that solution or i think what
is done in practice is usually
you run a mip solver and you take the
solution from the mib solver
so how good so this is another approach
then core guided so how how do they
compare
so with the caveat that i have
not done research on this um
but i've talked to colleagues
who who know this better than i do and
they're fairly consistent in saying that
it's not the case that
either approach dominates the other so
it seems that
implicit hitting set and core guided
have complementary strengths
for max hat problems where you have many
soft clauses with the same weights that
are somehow interchangeable and the
important thing
isn't exactly which soft closes you
violate it's more like about the count
of how many soft clauses you need to
violate core guided seems better because
it will allow you
to abstract away and somehow give you
this
count it doesn't necessarily care about
which clauses
it will just know how many clauses
you're violating
however uh for max hat problems where
you have many distinct weights it seems
that the implicit heating set approach
is
often better um
this is all based on intuition though so
a very nice question uh
for the theoreticians listening to this
would be
to study the proof complexity of core
guided search
an implicit hitting set and try to
provide precise characterizations
compare the two approaches
maybe you can prove some simulation
results or separation results
there is some work in this direction
but there's definitely room for more
other open questions since
implicit hitting set and core guided are
complementary
why not try to combine them so it turns
out that
this someone that you already thought
about this there is some recent work on
this but
again my impression is that it's not the
final word
there should be more things that can be
done here
another idea is to think about well can
you do implicit heating set for
general pseudo-boolean optimization
so now remember that we don't have
course and soft clauses here we just
have an objective function and literals
so the so-called course will just be
learned pseudo-boolean constraints over
literals in the objective function so
then what is a hitting set
well a hitting set will be a partial
assignment that is guaranteed
to satisfy all of these constraints note
that if these constraints are clauses
then the hitting set is really just a
hitting set because you know
for every constraint that you only need
to satisfy one literal
in c and then the clause is satisfied in
general
if the cis are suitable and constraints
then you might need to set several
literals
to be sure to satisfy um this constraint
and you'll get some kind of generalized
hitting set
that does this in as cheap a way
as possible to the best of my knowledge
this has not been implemented
in a native sudo boolean solver i think
it would be very interesting to
do it
but but that's
a future research direction
that ends part three
of this tutorial so we've now talked
about
what pseudo-boolean problems are how to
solve decision problems
how to solve optimization problems but
as you saw
the annoying thing is as we developed
these
solvers often not always but often it
turned out that
mixed integer linear programming solvers
were also
very good at solving these problems or
even better so in the
fourth and final part of this
pre-recorded tutorial
we'll talk a little bit about what these
mixed integer
linear programming solvers are how they
work
and what we can do about the fact that
they're
so good so we can try to beat them or we
can try to join them or maybe do
both but to hear more about that you
have to tune in
for the fourth and final part of this
tutorial this
ends part three
you